south africa
is struggling dozens of people have died
and more than 2 000 have been arrested
and countless businesses
have been ransacked but what has been
going
on exactly in south africa
[Music]
it all started with the arrest of the
former president jacob zuma
i'm not scared of doing
off going to jail for my beliefs
he was arrested at the start of july
after being sentenced to a 15-month
jail term for refusing to take part into
an inquiry
into corruption during his 10-year
presidency
he was forced from office by his own
party after mounting evidence of rampant
corruption in his administration
including claims his cabinet
appointments and lucrative contracts
were influenced by family and friends
his family and supporters called for a
national shutdown
and groups on whatsapp circulated voice
notes
urging people to take to the streets but
these protests transformed
into something bigger the unrest fueled
by frustration
in a country where millions of people
live life
on the edge
what started as political unrest has
swiftly turned into violence
looting and rioting
[Music]
and what about zuma are people doing
this for zuma
i think there's no there is no food more
than half of south africa's 60 million
people
are living in poverty with an
unemployment rate
pushing 40 percent an economic crisis
job cuts youth unemployment and of
course a global pandemic
have worsened the situation across the
country
and these protests suggest that many
have had enough
in short a lot of damage
thousands of people have stolen food
electronics
alcohol and clothes from shops and malls
in the provinces
of kwazulu-natal and halting
vehicles have been burnt and businesses
vandalized
with debris left strewn across the roads
dozens of people have been killed in the
resulting violence
some were trampled to death in stampedes
as people looted shops
police have arrested more than 2 000
people
and they've used stun grenades and
rubber bullets against the looters
but they seem powerless to actually stop
the unrest
highway of death gulf war that's what it
looks like down here if you carry on
further down the road
the car's burnt out red cars on the road
they've looted everything the
factories are burning warehouses are
burning the military
have been ineffectual so far they carry
live ammunition
but they are not permitted to use it
it's difficult to see how the
authorities are going to get a grip on
this situation
the violence and the unrest spread
quickly here
and there doesn't seem to be an end in
sight
we will restore calm and order so that
we can get on with the task of
rebuilding this country
the country's president cyril ramaphosa
has pleaded for calm
and he's deployed south africa's
military on the streets
but another politician minister kobutsu
chaveni
told sky news that youth unemployment is
a ticking
time bomb that is going to explode
and there are very real concerns that
the rioting and the unrest
will lead to widespread food shortages
people in durban
now have to queue up for hours to access
a handful of shops
that have opened their doors and people
here have told us
they worry the looters will soon turn up
here and shut this supermarket down